camia lui bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sur arte france vous avez été donc
relaxé comment avez vous accueilli cette
nouvelle nous aujourd'hui on s'est rendu
compte avec l'observation qu'on fait non
seulement sur le terrain mais dans les
tribunaux que apporté la preuve de ce
qu'on démontre mais n'est pas forcément
ne m'apporte pas forcément une relaxe à
on a par exemple on a un manifestant qui
avait été accusé d'avoir fait des
violences sur un policier en septembre
et il a été incarcéré
notamment suite à des mensonges
policiers et c'est seulement en appel
en produisant notre vidéo que nous avons
pu démontrer que les policiers avaient
menti donc
donc en fait voilà c'était pas garanti
qu'est une relaxe dans mon cas non plus
parce que parce que voilà il faut il
faut vraiment appuyé sur les éléments de
preuve qu'on amène mai donc c'est
effectivement ça aboutit ici encore à
une relaxe parce que je rappelle que en
2019 donc j'ai fait l'objet de deux
procès deux procès qui était qui étaient
infondées qui m'ont fait faire des
dizaines d'heures de garde à vue je
rappelle que j'ai fait cinquante six
heures de garde à vue pour pour alors
que je n'ai commis aucune infraction et
donc voilà ça aboutit sur une relaxe
encore une fois alors vos observations
ont contribué à la rédaction de
plusieurs rapports il ya des saisines de
l'igpn pour des cas d'allégation usage
illégal de la force vous êtes sur le
terrain
qu'avez vous vu et qu'avez vous
rapporter alors je tiens à souligner que
les violences que nous constatons sont
faites vraiment enfin on voit bien que
c'est pas des erreurs un c'est pas c'est
pas des policiers qui sont acculés dans
un coin et qui n'ont d'autres moyens que
d'utiliser leurs armes
ce qu'on voit c'est par exemple des tirs
tendus de gaz lacrymogènes un tir tendu
de avec un lanceur cougar ça veut dire
que les projectiles vont percuté les
corps des manifs et
cent alors que la loi prévoit qu'ils
doivent être tirées vers le ciel
justement pour qu'il n'y a pas de corps
de manifestants percuté de même pour la
grenade inde d encerclement qui est
lancée par dessus l'épaule alors que la
loi prévoit qu'elle doit être lancée
impérativement au ras du sol c'était
gestes qu'ils sont délibérément fait en
vue de mutiler et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui se passe nous comptons plus les les
mules les mutilés à montpellier nous
avons eu 1 et bords nié par une grenade
mains de désencerclement qui avait 18
ans dylan 18 ans le 27 avril sur la
place de la préfecture c'est
inadmissible et c'est encourager ça a
été encouragée par le gouvernement
pendant un an qui a instrumentalisé sa
police et maintenant on voit qu'il a
l'intention de la trahir j'invite
toujours plus les policiers non
seulement à ne pas se conformer à des
ordres illégal ou à utiliser le cadre le
cadre qu'ils ont pour pour exercer des
violences gratuites
parce que derrière ils ne sont pas
garanties d'être soutenus jusqu'au bout
alors quand vous êtes sur les terrains
je le répète comment jugez-vous usage de
la force par la police lors des
rassemblements gilet jaune alors il a il
y a il faut bien sûr distinguer c'est au
cas par cas s'est passé dans des
situations précises qu'il faut évaluer
cette force dans tous les cas mais nous
avons constaté de nombreux cas d' usage
non nécessaire et non proportionnée
c'est à dire des usages illégaux
vraiment il ya eu et on a fait des
rapports plusieurs rapports que ce soit
l'observatoire des pratiques policières
de montpellier mais aussi celui de
toulouse celui de bordeaux à paris il ya
de nombreuses villes dans lesquelles des
de nombreux rapports ont été faits et
donc les violences sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup trop nombreuses en fait pour
pour qu'on dise que c'est seulement des
cas isolés
en fait ce sont des violences qui sont
utilisés comme un système c'est une
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre il ya le
l'état a clairement voulu réprimer son
peuple pendant un an et c'est c'est
inadmissible peut-être très rapidement
un mot sur la sphère cédric joue bien
une information judiciaire pour homicide
involontaire a été ouverte par le
parquet sa famille ses proches eux
parlent de violence policière on l'a vu
les vidéos ont circulé que pensez vous
de cette affaire je pense qu'une
fracture du larynx c'est tout de même
c'est tout de même
'l'indice d'une violence particulière
d'un acharnement particulier et et
sincèrement moi même j'ai déjà constaté
dans le cadre de mes missions
d'observation un une clé d'étranglement
et un plaquage ventrale j'étais à un
mètre et demi de la scène c'est julia
intégralement filet mais cette scène et
j'ai été profondément choqué par ces
techniques d'interpellation qui n'était
d'ailleurs dans le cas que j'ai examiné
pas du tout justifiée et donc je ne
saurais pas parlé du cas de cédric joue
via mais par contre c'est des techniques
qui sont extrêmement violente et qui ne
sont pas utiles en tout cas dans le cas
que j'ai pu que j'ai pu constater qu a
mis à nu merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
observatrice pour la ligue des droits de
l'homme et que vous avez été relaxé hier
merci